so welcome to this lost webcast from the
ftth conference here in Stockholm and
stockin's meson I'm much reading from
telecom near Tana the media partner of
the ftth conference and with me I have
Hartwig Talbert the general manager of
FTTH Council Europe and not yet by bali
their communications director
communications director that's good
we're in Stockholm we've been in
Stockholm for 33 days Odrick can you say
what would has been the best the best
has been stockholm in a hole it was a
real big show we are really proud of
having this show here up in the in the
Nordics and it was huge we can really
say it was again the biggest FTTH show
in the world 3,000 people coming here
showing up in the exhibition hall in the
conference 85-84 countries being
presented in stockholm which means of
course it's got some kind of world
capital of fiber in the last days and we
had already the workshops which is
normally a small part small part of the
conference 1300 delegates listening to
very specific topics so I would say the
best in Stockholm was it was a wonderful
conference and we really appreciate it
to be here no yeah sure yes I think what
I could add is that of course I'm also
extremely pleased and I think people are
walking around with the smiling faces in
the in the expo and in the conference
room so it shows that people are quite
happy the food was very nice and we even
had snow today which a lot of people
expected here in Stockholm but what I
would add to hartwig's remarks is that
the theme of this conference is
showcasing a brighter future and this is
why we came to stuck on one of the
historic leaders in five to the home
where because fiber was deployed such a
long time ago we have this unique chance
of seeing the services that of FTTH
enabled
and so it is a real showcase of those
services as well and that was extremely
interesting to summarize this event you
started up with the workshops which had
a fantastic crowd I mean 1300 instead of
eight I've heard a number earlier about
800 was the expected number of
participants and you reach almost a
double yes this was a very big success
for us we two years ago started with
this workshop saying we want to in
addition to the normal conference tracks
give the people the possibility to
really dig deep into a specific topic
beat technology regulation services and
that's why we started up this workshops
not knowing how much attraction they
will get and from day one they were
really one of the success factors again
of this conference and this year we made
it in a way that we said let's have 12
of these workshops in parallel let's
offer our members the possibility to
work together to create very specific
workshops and it really worked out very
well and the interesting thing was even
we had a broad range of topics as I said
it's starting from technology services
regulation all these kind of things all
of these topics very appreciated by the
people which shows us that the delegates
coming to our conference really covered
the whole value chain of fiber networks
starting from the planning and
Technology part up to the financial part
to the implementation and running part
and I believe that's a very good news
for us were there any of these workshops
that had more more participants than you
had expected we had a lot of
participants in the workshop of world of
applications where we said what can you
do with fiber networks and we were
really surprised about the huge group
this was the workshop we even had to
move from one room to another one
because the number of seats suddenly was
too small and the number of people who
wanted into the room exceeded the
capacity and so we even had to do some
logistics and thats something i really
want to mention here the flexibility of
the stock homes mess on the venue that
did a great job in a calm
dating all these special things for us
which really meant people felt well
treated felt well serviced even if there
is a small changes in the in the program
that's that's perfect have there been a
lot of talking after the workshops have
you heard anything specific have you are
people talking about it indeed David one
of the most things I heard was people
asking have you been at the workshops
and the other says no unfortunately not
and then the answer was out then you
missed something so we hope that next
year this means a lot of people who just
arrived for the conference will then
join the workshops too because they
realize this is a real added value to
the conference and from the topic wise
we had two conference or workshop tracks
or two workshops running on technology
one on the basic information about fiber
so what is it how can you install it
what is the technology behind it and one
that went further into details what are
the new trends and I realized here even
you would say most of the people know
everything about fiber that these were
really the workshops where a lot of
people said it was a perfect source for
me to get either an update or to really
get a deep insight into into the topic
from the technology side so that was the
highlights of the workshop day you can
say indeed and then the first real
conference day you made a surprising
entrance the both of you came down from
sky like the brightness of the industry
yes actually we came down actually the
brightest of the industry is another way
of putting it but it was actually mentor
as fiber enabled super citizens which
was one of the themes of this conference
because it's based on the showcase of
the services and showing how people when
they have these applications and
services become a different person and
get enabled get it you know special
power they have more time you know to
spend with their families and and things
like that and so I invite
viewers of of this interview to actually
check out the clip of the opening
session because then they can see the
opening clip and our descent onto the
stage were you ever afraid because I'm
really afraid of heights and being sent
down like that I would been really
afraid especially I've been stuck up
there hanging on the middle yes it was
no it was not not scary but yes we were
hanging in in in the dark before we came
down that was fun it was great fun I
really enjoyed it we had to do it at
some point and we did it this year and
I'm glad we did this in Stockholm also
it was fun yeah and then you started up
with several famous speakers you had the
the main speaker for for the for that
morning was Anna Coren hot the Swedish
IT minister itn energy minister any
special remarks on her speech yes we
were really pleased of course that we
had such high level people from Sweden
at the conference because this shows the
strong support of Sweden of the
government of the local authorities here
in Stockholm for such a conference and
45 of the home and the messages from the
minister were really strong saying that
it you need to think about the fact that
she's representing a government that
already started 14 years ago talking
about fiber which means they are much
more hit than many other governments in
Europe and so if you heard your messages
you saw it's already two strips three
steps further than what you see in other
countries for example the message saying
yes we have done the first two million
households but now we need to continue
to make the next one's ready to really
fiber eyes the whole of Sweden to make
sure that the inclusion is done which
means really everyone gets gets fiber I
think that strong messages because that
really says we take it serious we want
to create a very positive environment to
get 50 to the home done and this of
course is one of the most important
things to make fiber-to-the-home
happening
because it enables the project they
investors the operators to start
deploying the fiber networks or to
continue to deploy it because they
really find a very positive environment
we think other politicians from other
countries will get inspired by this
speech we would be happy to see this so
having maybe in a few years the German
Chancellor Angela Merkel getting on
stage and saying we want to fiber eyes
our 40 million household that would be a
nice message instead of saying we just
want to get 50 megabits done in the next
year's because that's something we don't
need to do some efforts on so I think it
would be nice if the message could be
taken as an example and then like we
said showcasing brighter future
realising let's implement it everywhere
in Europe were there anything else worth
mentioning from the speeches that
morning yesterday in from my side all
the speeches were impressive impressive
in a way that the messages were strong
they were all pro fiber they had
thinking about the mayor of stockholm
for example saying that by having this
fiber network in place again don't
forget they started deploying the fiber
20 years ago they already have earned
back the investment and had a benefit
out of it just due to the fact that out
of cheaper of connections for the
municipality out of health services they
could optimize and all these kind of
effects it had already had a positive
effect on the on the city itself I
believe that's also strong message
because that means it is more than fast
internet it is an infrastructure that
helps the society and even helps the
whole economy at the end and therefore
the speech that followed the mayor by
the regulator supporting this and saying
again we need to make sure that everyone
gets it so that this thing he called it
inclusion and I like this word this was
really really great messages yeah I
heard about the Yaran marble speech your
marble
that the regulator here in Sweden and
also the boss of a barrack yeah yes he
so he that's the good thing for us this
year Guren Bobby is of course the
chairman of the pts the post and and
telecom Authority and he's representing
all the regulators from all of Europe in
in the body of European regulators for
electronic communication as you said
barrack they always have huge names for
for it and I believe that a strong
signal because this could help to get
also the message through the regulators
in in other countries in Europe and we
are really happy about this were there
anything else worth mentioning from
yesterday did you catch up any talk of
the town yesterday evening what were
people talking about were there any
seminar so speakers that yes I was
surprised that people first of all and I
need to mention this we had this year a
different way of creating the program in
a way that we'd said let's bring in new
topics and let's bring in new speakers
to get new aspects into the into the
conference and this was one of the
discussions in the evening where the
people reacted very positive I just to
do a quick summary we had the Nordic
operators showing how they deployed
fiber and there were a lot of people
discussing it and saying how could they
do with it why was the market
environment so positive for them and of
course when we heard the message that
they have not too big problems to
connect users that they say ah but then
user demand is there so these were the
messages that came out of these North we
call it FTD agent in Nordic sessions
then we had a very lively discussion and
the regulatory and policy side normally
this is the dry things where you talk
about legal stuff but this year we said
let's have an open discussion between
the difference they called us from
Europe but also outside Europe so we had
people from Asia here we had people from
the US here and we had two speakers from
one from the European Commission and one
from the Parliament here and the debate
that started there was I would say
more than lively so some things were
discussed in a more direct way than you
would sometimes expect it on stage this
is something if someone watches the
recording of these sessions this is a
highlight i would i would have a look at
it in addition we had of course the
update of our market data so we
presented yesterday in detail how did
the fiber market develop and how will it
look like in the next five years with
the good news that we have a good
increase of fiber connections last year
and which is I think even more important
on the business case side the take-up
rate that means the percentages of
households who connect to an existing
fiber network increased relatively
strongly last year which means the
operators really started to feel end
users have the demand for fiber this
session with the market data was then
closed with the discussion of the global
FTTH councils which was a unique
opportunity to have a full global
overview what was happening on all the
on the fiber markets all over the world
and I heard a lot of people saying while
this is on one spot the whole world
summarized and by people who are living
there and know their markets very well
on the technology side we had two
sessions that really showed the newest
solutions of fiber and these rooms were
again packed with people because they
wanted to listen what are the new
technology is what are the new products
and what are the new solutions to
install these products so this this was
talk of course of the more technical
experts at the end and we also started
in new track this year on gaming
computer gaming and we had an
interesting experience with this one
because a lot of people seem not to dare
to go into this session because gaming
is still a bit of a strange strange
topic it's for the young ones yeah yes
like me yeah I'm a gamer I I admit this
so I love gaming and the interesting
thing was those who dare to auto who
went there came out afterwards and said
hey this is
we should focus more on because it's a
completely new idea to do so there was a
lot of discussions just about the first
day yeah and if you want to catch up
with this you could always log into T V
dot ftth Council EU where we have
collected all of these streams now what
were your largest highlights from
yesterday I think the highlights and
would be for me on the services sighs
and I think what to build on what
Hardwick said on the opening speakers i
think the the good news is that with
hindsight politicians on national your
local level regulatory level they are
all saying it was the right thing to do
which a lot of governments and other
countries who have not yet made the
decision to go to go for fiber to the
home would you know see from that clear
message that there even though they
started already 20 years ago in Sweden
they are saying we need to do more we
need to continue because it was the
right thing to do I think that is a huge
positive message on top of and that is
actually proven by the fact that
customers want fiber and will pay for it
if it is available so I think it's
really you know that that was really a
highlight for me and I think what we see
here as a showcase of ftth enabled
services and applications so not just in
the conference but also in the expo and
actually in what is happening today
there are some sessions where we invited
yesterday there was a session on the
smart smart everything yeah where people
talked about you know all the different
from smart grid to connected objects and
today we have some sessions on a health
and II care there are hardly talked
about the gaming industry which by the
way Sweden is really strong in that
field so there's really a huge range of
opportunities for innovations in service
is enabled by fiber to the home and so
several sessions covered those topics
yesterday and also today and this
morning wasn't only presenting a
brighter future it presented also a
brighter Stockholm with the lots of snow
for our delegates to walk Aryan and the
morning started with the price ceremony
yes this morning and it is a tradition
that we the f th Council Europe and has
a prize which is called the ftth cancel
Europe award and that award is given to
one individual and one operator so there
are two awards actually who in the past
year have made a significant
contribution to ftth adoption in Europe
and this year was extremely interesting
we the operator award was awarded to
Vodafone for its FTTH rollouts in
Portugal Spain and Italy and the
individual award was given to third
child cow who is the person who won the
Nobel Prize in 2009 for inventing the
way that we use fiber optics for
communications by the way it's a Nobel
Prize in Physics and his wife Gwen cow
came all the way from Hong Kong to
collect this price since such as cow
these and she is yes she is absolutely
amazing she's fantastic I think you had
her years yeah we had her hair in the
studio and she was absolutely fantastic
yeah such a sweet lady and very well
informed she attended all the sessions
and came back to me before she left
today she said yes it was so interesting
so I think yeah it was really great to
have her here yeah and then you start to
continued with with some speakers you
had for instance appear so don't know
from EU yeah we had we had two
high-level people from the European
Union one was piercer Donahoe the deputy
head of the cabinet of Commissioner Cruz
so from
the DG connect and we had mep hurt mark
we call him to mr. gigabit of the
European Parliament because he was the
first one clearly also in Parliament
saying we need gigabit speeds and that's
quite a strong push forward and it was
really interesting to hear both of them
giving their messages that I would say
the commission of costs rise always to
state technology neutral but still
that's slight twist towards fiber so
they understand there is no way out that
in one one point of time fiber is
necessary of course our mr. gigabit so
MEP Herc mark he could be more direct so
he really made some strong statement
saying we need to go and it was
fascinating sitting in the audience and
sometimes seeing him addressing directly
the mr. O'Donohoe saying we need to do
we need to do so this is quite a strong
way of communicating of course that mr.
Herk mark is also from sweden helped a
lot towards this one but i believe that
that was a real good real good opening
session and so this is something we for
sure we'll make do again in the next
conference yeah and then from today's
seminars do you have any highlights have
you heard anything special we had of
course following the the opening
ceremony we had again a co panel this is
every year a very big project to bring
high level cos into our conference and
we had people from the industry we had
the CEO of T connectivity Tom Lynch here
we had CEOs from operators here like
telenor from companies like ska Nova and
I think this makes a really nice
combination of high-level decision
makers in the industry and in the
operator side who give their insights
and having them at the ftth conference
which means we also can show them our
messaging and then seeing like today in
the co panel that they are in line with
most of what we are saying is a very
positive signal for us and I think
that's that's a good way forward
heard a lot of that debate from the
floor when I've been out walking a lots
of people are talking about that CEO
panel anything more yes I mean if the
program was of course running continuing
running so we had a lot of sessions
running today I was surprised we had one
academic session which means we invited
a university saying look you have a
session talk about your approach on
fiber and they decided to do an applied
approach so not at theoretical one but
saying what are the typical issues on
business case on users experience and
this kind of stuff and I was surprised
because it was one of the sessions now
in the afternoon and they had a huge
crowd of people sitting in listening to
this kind of topics of course getting
them in it in a different way so it's
interesting to see that the academic
world at least of the Applied Sciences
part is very close to the industry today
so this really worked out well again
today we had sessions on technology
which were very extremely successful and
Nadia mention did we had application
sessions during the day on a health so
we called it the ftth can save your life
on entertainment where we heard about
new ways of watching TV and we saw very
clearly these are topics that we need to
cover because this is how to fill the
pipe and here I hurt just when I came in
here already people talking about about
this and then of course getting to
things like 4k TV and realizing this is
reality and not something that is coming
in in many years from now yeah and it's
a few hours to go here in Stockholm and
then next year we're going to were so in
Poland indeed that will be a change and
yes we are going to also in Poland the
the ftth market is really growing in the
eastern part of Europe now we're there
the broadband networks are usually quite
obsolete so there
is a big move for to renew the
infrastructure and build fiber to the
home networks because it is a no-brainer
if you are building a network then you
are going to build a pipe to the home
network and we wanted to move also our
event which is changing we change we
move from one city to the next every
year we wanted to also move towards the
eastern side of Europe and so this term
this is why we we decided to go to also
even though Poland so far is not yet in
the ranking of countries where more than
one percent of the population is
connected to fibre to the home which
means there is still work to be done
there and I hope that having our event
in also will also raise the awareness of
politicians and users even operators
investors about fiber and I think this
is something that I would also say that
you can really see here in in Sweden is
that there there is general awareness
about fiber to the home not just in the
telecoms industry but the politicians
the end-users people know about that and
that is key to the development of and
user demand of course if the ant user
does not hear about it then yeah have
you set any topic and headline for for
for the Warsaw event we will food be
working on this and but we already have
selected a venue and we already have
dates so i can tell you that it will be
from the ten to the twelfth of februari
2015 in expo 21 which is a big congress
center sorry a big exhibition center in
a row so cool that will be amazing to go
to Poland don't think I've been there
ever well so then it's a great chance
for you yeah to get there so to
summarize Stockholm if you could do in a
extremely short executive summary of the
Stockholm events what would you say
can I start I will just say one thing
ftth enables super citizen and it
showcases a brighter future it was just
great to be here thank you very much for
coming to my hometown and then we are
finishing the loft webcast from this
year's FTTH conference the largest FTTH
event in the world in stockholm this
year thank you very much for watching us